[Music]  Parliament enters the final phase of its  future of Europe debates ahead of the  European elections in May with the  Spanish Prime Minister Pedro Sanchez as  Romania takes over the rotating  presidency of the European Council MEP s  will discuss priorities for the next six  months they'll also look back at the  achievements of Austria's presidency the  single currency was launched two decades  ago on the first of January 1999 to mark  the 25th we call technology MEP s will  discuss harmonizing technical standards  and safety rules and how to ensure the  sector gets sufficient support  Parliament votes on new rules to freeze  EU funding to member states jeopardizing  the rule of law interfering with the  judiciary or failing to adequately  tackle corruption  [Music]